42 billion dollars can disappear
overnight
and we don't know the outcomes of that
and if people realize they have this
power what is the backlash from the
state as well which is one of the big
battles we've all been facing is stay
overreach how does this all play out and
one of the ways it's going to play out
in the financial markets is
all right guys I thought now in the
middle of a crisis it'd be a great
moment to bring on the one and only role
Paul I thought maybe the place to start
here is how did we arrive at The Current
financial crisis that we're experiencing
can you take us back to 2020 and kind of
explain how we got into this situation
well it's actually pretty contentious
because nobody agrees on why or how
my view on all of this is that
2020 obviously the world had shut down I
remember you and I speaking just before
it happened
and what happened is the global economy
stopped entirely and to stimulate it as
everybody was at home
they both
undertook massive amounts of
quantitative easing but also they did
something different which was fiscal
stimulus direct handouts
so as we started pulling through the
business cycle as the world started
reopening then the inflation Genie that
comes from fiscal stimulus which is very
common not from monetary stimulus we'll
come on to that later
that started appearing in the global
economy
and the Central Bank started to hike
rates they started late they didn't
think it was going to come as big as it
was then Russia invaded Ukraine and
obviously all commodity prices go
through the roof Supply Chains Get
shattered and that exacerbated the
existing Supply chains because people
weren't back in the workforce all of
that stuff factories weren't ready so we
start with this big inflationary
pressure so the Federal Reserve then
decide to hike rates at the fastest rate
of change in all recorded history
and eventually
that tends to lead to a
the kind of negative side of the
business cycle
so that starts playing out the
forward-looking indicators start falling
suggesting we're going to go into
recession which everyone's been talking
about and a lot of people have been
saying well what's going to break if you
raise rates this month something's going
to break and eventually it was the
banking system and it's all a story as
ever of too much Leverage
so what's fascinating to me about this
entire situation is that when the FED
began to hike interest rates
people called it out they said hey
they're going to keep doing this until
things break is the Federal Reserve and
other central banks when they do this
intentionally going to just move until
something breaks but they don't actually
know what's going to break and they just
figure that they'll deal with it later
or do they have an understanding that
hey the banking system will come under
pressure later like how aware are they
of where uh the braking will happen
versus they just kind of say look we got
to get rates up we know things will
break and we'll just deal with it when
they arrive
I I don't think they're Machiavellian in
we're going to break something
what they're trying to do is slow the
business cycle down because that's how
you get rid of inflation
now always at the bottom of every
business cycle whether it was 1990 2000
2001 2008 uh 2020 always something
breaks because of rates and a slowing
economy
so that's just a function of what
happens in a business cycle much like
there's a boom at the peak of the
business cycle and usually kind of
excess leverage and excess optimism so I
don't think they try to break it now
it's coming out that you know obviously
the FED kind of knew that the regional
Banks weren't great we also know the
pension system's a problem we also know
there's a number of things that can be a
problem in this system when you've got a
globally indebted situation like we've
got today the world has never been this
far in debt and no country in in world
history has ever been as far in debt as
the US is as a percent of GDP so it's
problematic but they kind of that's just
a function of the business cycle
when you see what's going on with these
Banks let's go right there because I
think that is probably the first time
that something broke and people started
to pay attention uh as a friend told me
they said bodies keep floating to the
surface uh in this entire situation why
are the banks under so much stress like
what has happened inside of a bank that
has put them in this position
okay it's actually really simple
so there's two levels for what a bank is
it is the deposits that they have that's
what makes them a bank and that's what
they do with the deposits they invest
them
so in a normal course events Banks make
business by something called the Steep
yield curve so they borrow at let's say
two percent interest rates I they pay
you two percent on your deposit and they
lend it out to the market at five
percent that's the yield curve so that's
a longer term duration
um that they take the risk on
the issue is the yield curve got
massively negative in fact the second
most negative yield curve since 1980
so that means that the banks ordinarily
would have to pay you five percent or
four percent interest on your deposit
but then they invest it in the bond
market in 20-year bonds or 10-year bonds
or 30-year bonds and they're actually
getting less money so they're losing
money every day
so what they did is artificially change
the yield curve so they said well we're
actually going to give you half a
percent interest in your money and then
we can lend it out in the bond market
and something different
at a higher rate so they've manufactured
a steeper yield curve the issue is is
people have the freedom to move their
deposits so they can move their deposits
out of this half a percent world into a
five percent world of CDs you know uh
treasury direct money market funds so
people are incentivized to move their
deposits because the rate of interest is
actually the highest we've seen for a
long time so people are incentivized to
do that that means deposits shrink from
the system as they shrink you have to
unwind the bets that you had at the long
end the longer maturity bets now the
problem is is those are all underwater
because the FED raise rates so much so
then they've got losses Mark to Market
losses but to collapse the deposit base
you have to realize those losses
normally you can just leave them on your
book as Mark to market accounts you
don't need to worry about it but in this
case you have to do something about it
suddenly poof they're all got no money
so that's the real issue here now there
is a big ship fight going on about what
people should do about it what what the
the government should do about it what
the Federal Reserve should do about it
people say well if people are getting
scared now because they saw Silicon
Valley Bank and Signature Bank go under
well we should just guarantee deposits
in the system
okay sounds great
problem is it doesn't get rid of the
actual issue the actual issue is the
rates are too damn High
so the the banks can't make any money so
they if if they just guaranteed the
deposits people still go to treasury
direct and get their four and a half or
five percent yields so it doesn't stop
it slows it down somewhat but it's still
a huge problem
the only answer here the only answer
that they have is to massively cut rates
and I think 300 basis Points Plus
and also undertake QE
the reason I have to undertake QE is the
banks particularly these Regional Banks
smaller medium-sized banks have another
big issue on their balance sheet and
that is they are the largest lenders to
the commercial real estate market
now if we go back to when we first spoke
at the beginning of the pandemic
at that point we were all going to the
office
I was in New York when I saw you because
I was going to the office and we had 16
odd people in our office at real Vision
now we've got three people in office
we've downsized once and we still only
have three people in the office and we
can't get out of our damn lease and
everybody's got the same issue
nobody's going back to the office the
world has changed we can all work
remotely so we used to do interviews
like this in person now we do them over
Zoom
so then we've got massive amounts of
commercial real estate that are
basically empty and the numbers are a
bit weird because you also need to
realize that empty office space that's
registered is entirely empty but
actually most people are trapped into
leases where they've got 10 of their
Workforce going in so as soon as those
Lucius come up people are going to tip
those out too so we've got a second bomb
to hit these smaller Banks and that is
this real estate market and the real
estate market is going to be illiquid
and chances are it's not going to get
solved
I mean I spoke to one of the biggest
managers of commercial real estate for
one of the biggest Pension funds the
United States and he's like they're
going to bulldoze over this stuff in the
end because people are never going to
use this yes we can repurpose some of it
for residential property but actually
it's quite different difficult from
regulatory reasons and how you fit
plumbing and all sorts of weird stuff so
he said look you know we can repurpose
some of this stuff but a lot of this
stuff is just going to get bulldozed
into the ground in the end and that's in
10 years time because there's nobody
going to use that real estate so
somebody has to pay that now that would
ordinarily mean this is like the Savings
and Loans crisis in the 1980s and 90s it
drags on and on and on
but we've changed the game here because
we know the answer the answer is what
Mario draghi did in Europe in 2013 12.
um and I saw this firsthand I was living
in Spain what draggy did is say we'll
take all of the [__] on your balance
sheet we don't care what it is screwed
up Bits of Paper anything we'll just
lend against it to keep the banking
system insolvent and then slow manage
the decline of the banking system
um that's the position we're going to
have to be in these small to Regional
banks will never recover regardless
because they've got too much commercial
real estate not all of them have but the
vast majority have and then they've got
the the problem with the current problem
which is the deposits are leaving the
system and the um and their Investments
are underwater so it's a big mess so the
short-term issue needs to get solved by
cutting rates really fast not
backstopping deposits doesn't help and
then we've got the bigger problem is
what the hell do you do with all this
junk on their balance sheets and we know
the answer it was invented in 2008 we
actually came out Japan beforehand is
the central bank will put it on their
balance sheet in the end so there's a
couple of things in here that I think
are worth kind of unpacking um let's
talk about what I'll call the immediate
crisis which is uh these Bank runs that
occurred really Silicon Valley Bank I
think is probably the biggest uh victim
of one of them but there was a little
bit at silvergate and uh and signature I
think that Regulators are trying to say
that uh there was concern there but but
let's use Silicon Valley Bank as the
example
one of the aspects of this that I don't
think anyone really understood prior to
when that occurred is this idea of a
digital crisis right and so in a digital
crisis I don't have to go to the bank
and stand in line and wait my turn to
try to withdraw my money I can get on my
computer click a button and move my cash
and then I can move that from my deposit
account into a money market fund into
treasury some other type of asset or I
can move it from that bank to another
bank and in this Digital World the
velocity at which this can happen
obviously led into Silicon Valley Bank
having 42 billion dollars of withdrawals
in a 24-hour period was just an insane
number to think about
backstopping the deposits seems to be
trying to address that problem is that
how you read the backstopping of
deposits and why they're making such a
big kind of deal about stepping in with
these different facilities
yeah so let's go back and understand why
this increasingly rapid
digital issue
has evolved it came out of Occupy Wall
Street where people said kind of enough
is enough they then started coalescing
online and we saw that in Wall Street
bets where people realize that together
they could take on the system
and together that they could
put the odds in their favor a bit more
so now armed with the information of
what I call the hive mind which is this
kind of mass of all these smart people
saying Hey listen we've got a problem
here let's do something about it
that also turns into a mob mentality
so it can happen so fast so the whole
world works at Twitter speed now doesn't
work by going to the bank you know if
you're a member JP Morgan back in I
think it was 2000 1909
um slowed down a bank run by telling
tellers to count the cash twice and do
it really slowly and that slows this
kind of massive instant panic but we're
in a very very different world where
information spreads instantly and the
hive mind can turn into a mob as soon as
they sense fear
so you have to stop that because that's
the instantaneous death of banks
um and that's a problem we saw that
instantaneous with
um FTX we've seen it instantaneously in
the crypto markets so that is the new
modus operandi
so The Regulators need to deal with that
somehow so they can either throttle the
requests
or they can say there's no reason to do
that
but it still doesn't get rid of the
existing reason
which is the rates aren't high enough in
the bank so you're still incentivized
and also it's the Streisand Effect as
well it's kind of like nothing to see
here
tells people there's everything to see
and part of that is realizing that okay
if the outcome to some of this is
printing of money
well then the money hold in the bank is
going to be worth less in the future
so
people sense that even with a backstop
of the banking system
it's not going to solve everything it
might just stop an instant flight but
even that's not guaranteed
what I find fascinating about this is uh
if you spend a good amount of time on
Twitter you can very quickly feel when
things are changing I think in early
2020 you know maybe by end of February
early March it was obvious that like hey
something's up uh and I think that a lot
of people right now feel that way and
they're saying to themselves the gravity
of this situation is unlike something
that they've seen uh in a long time
which which that alone I think is
important to pay attention to you
mentioned FTX and I actually want to
make a comparison here and I'd love to
kind of get your reaction to it so we
know that cryptocurrency companies and
let's use FTX specifically as the
example and banks have a lot of uh
differences right there is FDIC
insurance for let's say a Silicon Valley
Bank there is no FDIC insurance for FTX
we know that uh what appears to have
happened at FTX is that they said they
were doing one thing with the deposits
and they did something else and so
obviously there's been huge Fallout same
freed has been arrested and there are
many allegations of Fraud and various
other nefarious or malicious types of
activities there
but at the end of the day FTX took in
customer deposits they took those
deposits regardless of what they said
they were doing with them and they
bought assets those assets did not go up
in value or make money they instead went
down there was unrealized and then
eventually realized losses when the bank
run happened and so kind of a bank run
exposed bad Investments with customer
deposits right in the most basic form of
FTX
if you now go and you look at a Silicon
Valley Bank it kind of sort of looks
like it's the same thing now again
there's FDIC Insurance uh the government
has stepped in to backstop the deposits
uh the bank appears to have said what
they were going to do with the deposits
is what they did but they took in
customer deposits they bought assets
they're bad bets they were unrealized
losses and then a bank run caused those
unrealized losses to become realized
losses and kind of expose this is that a
fair way to kind of look at the
similarities and differences between an
FTX and a Silicon Valley Bank there's a
key the mechanism is the same but
there's a key difference
F6 is a brokerage they're supposed to
keep customer deposits separate
and they don't have a right to use yours
a bank is in the business of using your
deposit to make bets
and
back in 2020
the the treasury changed the rules and
said you don't need Mark to Market
accounting because the bond market had
become illiquid
and that was okay
but it compounds this issue once
depositors leave so yes there is a
comparison that you took a you took
customer money and he made a bet one is
actually allowed the other one's not
allowed there's also a lot of Regulation
about what kind of bets you can take you
know we stopped the ability to have prop
trading in banks that went by the
wayside a while ago but FTX was
essentially prop trading with customer
money which they shouldn't have done
which was kind of more what MF Global
did when um
when John Corzine essentially took
brokerage deposits and better on the
European bond market and blew up and he
shouldn't have done that he was allowed
to do it at Goldman but it's a different
business brokerage you don't get the
rights to use the customer funds in a
bank people don't realize is you are the
product
um and that's very different
so when we go and we look at these Banks
you've mentioned that what is likely to
happen or what you think will occur is
uh Mario draghi and the idea of the
Central Bank coming and taking the
assets and putting on the central bank
balance sheet before you explain how
that works this idea of hold to maturity
I think is uh quite interesting uh
Balaji srinivasan has been calling it
hide to maturity but basically it's an
accounting mechanism that allows the
banks to hold assets that have traded
down or up in value uh and kind of
Market differently can you explain hold
to maturity and why that's so important
to this whole thing
so we've seen the bond market goes up
and down as all assets do but bonds are
kind of different because they're
guaranteed to pay you back if it's a U.S
treasury bond they can't go bus because
they can create money so they guarantee
to pay you back so if a bond is trading
90 cents
at the end of maturity it'll mature at
100.
so what the treasury said is
okay fine they move around
you are in the business of long-term
investing
so we'll assume you're going to hold it
to the end
so therefore you don't have to accept
the volatility in your portfolio which
creates other problems with
profitability and other issues so they
change the accounting rules so that is
that's the the halter maturity model
marked Market model means that bank
balance sheets go up and down and their
regulatory risk Capital goes up and down
depending what the bond Market's doing
every day
now we would have blown up the banks
earlier if they had marked a market
accounting which is every day you mark
your books because yields went up too
far and the FED had essentially told
them they're not going to raise rates so
they all got into the bond market that's
their job it's what they do they provide
essentially provide liquidity to the
treasury to buy bonds and they were
massively offside and that happens from
time to time it's a function of
financial markets but the hold to
maturity allows you to paper over the
cracks and and forget you got the BET
wrong Mark to Market accounting means
you have to take the BET as it happens
and the losses but what happened in this
situation is the depositors leaving
means you have to collapse this side
because you have leverage requirements
and therefore this side suddenly you've
got oh my God we've got these huge
losses so it turns hold to maturity into
Mark to Market in seconds and that's a
problem
so one of the aspects of this that um I
I find fascinating is that wall uh the
banks were taking those customer
deposits and they were buying longer
duration assets they obviously were
seeking higher yield we were in the zero
interest rate environment uh I have seen
people immediately point to and say well
the reason why they were doing that
regardless of risk management or hedging
or any of the other kind of knock-on
effects the reason why they were buying
those assets is because the federal
reserve's forward guidance was that
interest rates were still going to
remain low out you know 6 12 18 24
months and so the Federal Reserve ended
up changing their mind uh in response to
the economic environment and therefore
uh they went ahead and they jacked up
interest rates and that kind of left the
banks holding the bag now I think that
is a sympathetic view towards the FED I
think the critical view of the FED
people would argue is oh the FED said
one thing and they did another the FED
lied right it's kind of the most extreme
version of that how do you evaluate the
same situation right we know what has
happened so far but we have kind of
these sympathetic views and then we have
these critical views like is one or the
other right and doesn't even matter or
should we just focus on what's to come
in the future
at every bank there's a bunch of people
who run the capital of the bank it's
their [__] job to make the right risk
and they got it wrong not because the
FED told them anything their job is to
look forward in the business cycle and
make a decision do they think rates are
going up or not what really happened is
what nobody had on their bingo card was
Russia invading Ukraine that's what
caused the next big leg up in the bond
market so 10-year bond yields I'm just
looking at my chart now you know they
were chilling at about
one and three quarter percent
Russia invades Ukraine and they hit four
and a half percent 10-year bonds that
was the thing that nobody had
and that was the thing that broke the
banks because they were like we're
pretty comfortable maybe bond yields
move you know 100 basis points that's
all fine we've got we've got some holder
maturity accounting no problem Russia
invades Ukraine massive Supply shock
suddenly bond yields explode the Federal
Reserve have to fight it everyone was
offside and it just happens but the
question I would say is
and this is contentious one
is did the FED have any business raising
rates as much as they did or would would
the economy have slowed down anyway
because inflation ate into everybody's
pocketbooks companies started to see
slow down in growth anyway and the
supply chains were starting to ease up
so inflation probably would have Unwound
significantly so should the FED be at
the kind of level of rates that they are
at
or did they screw that part up and my
view which is often opposite to most
people is I don't think they should ever
raise rates this far it was stupid
um other people say well they shouldn't
have kept rates this low I don't know
because the economy Trend rate of growth
in the in the economy is like one and a
half percent one and three quarter
percent things are really slow we're
straddled with debts and we've seen
every time we raise rates the economy
collapses and it's not now just a
general recession we expose some big
ugly which is some leverage under the
rug
so one of the ideas that I'm fascinated
by and I don't necessarily have fully
formed opinion on this yet but it's a
topic that I call Financial Warfare and
what I mean by Financial Warfare is
let's talk uh Russia Ukraine first right
is Russia invading Ukraine uh elicited
Financial Warfare from the United States
we went ahead along with NATO and other
countries uh and sanctioned in what is
the most coordinated Financial uh
sanctioned kind of regime of any one you
know major country uh and for most
people I think they would argue it had a
great benefit some people might argue
that it wasn't as effective as we wanted
but either way we did it but also you
just mentioned that Russia's invasion of
Ukraine essentially created great
weakness in the American Financial
system it exposed a lot of these Banks
kind of left them holding the bag it
surprised the Federal Reserve you know
all these different components is that
the new normal now that we just should
see these countries all using the
financial weapons to go after each other
not just uh kind of guns bombs soldiers
Etc
yeah for sure
everybody knows including the US I mean
I've spoken to people at the Department
of Defense everyone knows that the issue
that the US has got is debt
and so they know that they've got
an angry population
they've got debt and you can upset the
apple cart pretty quick so I think
Russia kind of knew some of the economic
outcomes
and then in retaliation what we did was
ridiculous because we also took I mean
fine have sanctions no problem do all
the things you want to do but taking
people's private property without due
process
was outrageous taking essentially
neutralizing the reserves that they have
in dollars
sows the seeds of demise of the
dollar-based system now it's a long way
off because 87 of all World Trade is
still in dollars but when you tell
somebody your dollars that you've put
your com country Savings in are now not
accessible and by the way your private
property is going to be stolen from you
okay that's not good too
now we've also got another
geopolitical Financial Warfare that we
know could blow up at any point and
that's obviously China and Taiwan
and the reason why that's so important
is the entire world has one big
bottleneck well Energy's one bottleneck
silicon chips are another
and Taiwan is like the Saudi Arabia of
silicon chips
and who he who controls the chips
controls the flow of data and so that's
another one
and so I think we've seen from online
activity from
nefarious states that they understand
that the fabric of society in a
democracy in a situation like this is
more fragile than in an
um authoritarian State because the state
can clamp down on it
so it's harder for us to break Russian
Society in fact it's almost impossible
as Napoleon Hitler and everybody else
has tried to find and it's really hard
to break Chinese Society but it's much
easier to break
us UK or european Society so there's a
psychological warfare a financial
Warfare a physical Warfare
and a cyber warfare all going on at the
same time so a lot of folks when they
hear Financial Warfare they will think
internationally but I then want to bring
it home domestically I would argue that
a version of financial Warfare although
it wasn't fought by States uh was the
whole uh meme stocks GameStop uh the
Reddit crowd Etc these are people who
came together uh they were able to
coordinate resources and they were
basically able to affect change in the
market to express their view now that
view may be one of uh optimism for a
company it may also be one of uh
potential destruction of a company right
and so we saw this kind of weaponization
of uh retail investors with their money
but I saw something over the weekend
that made me pause and it was the first
time I'd ever seen this and it made me
say to myself we are headed towards a
world where there is digital crisis and
financial Warfare domestically that we
must be aware of it was a tweet from an
individual and I had about 10 000 likes
on it so it's a quite popular tweet and
he basically said referencing the
potential arrest of the former president
Trump he said wouldn't it be a shame if
all of the Trump supporters went on
Monday and conducted a bank run
and again forget for a second who
they're talking about in terms of the
presidential candidate forget the
politics but this idea that a group of
individuals I don't care if it's for
politics if it's for religious reasons
if it's for some sort of social cause
whatever but could recognize that the
American banking system or the financial
economy could be at a point of weakness
and then essentially use their own
Capital as individual citizens to
weaponize it
that scares the hell out of me
we are not prepared for [__] like this
and we'll talk we'll come to AI later
the classic way would have been to vote
or protest in the street but as you
mentioned before the world works at
Twitter speed
you can create false information or high
quality information instantaneously
coalesce enormous numbers of people at
the same time and we're seeing this with
this banking situation now
and we also know that there is a people
versus the state I mean what Balaji is
doing is trying to get people to
understand it's not about a million
dollar bet or Bitcoin going to a million
dollars it's about listen people we can
do something about this it's incredibly
empowering when it's the hive mind so in
balaji's view is listen the fractional
Reserve banking system is not good we
have a parallel system that's been built
Now's the Time to use the parallel
system totally agree
but you can also get anybody to do
anything online and we saw it over
covered the narratives the false
narratives the mistaken narratives the
narratives that were deemed to be false
and then proved to be true I mean it's a
mess
and Humanity's just playing out on
Twitter
um and Reddit and Tick Tock and
everywhere else in a way that
we can't comprehend as a society
how fast what is the unintended
consequences worms if they get something
wrong you know you'd argue that the the
Insurrection and the storming of of
um the government buildings was all part
of that where suddenly people got
deluded in thinking this was the right
thing to do and suddenly before you know
it the hive mind turns into a flash malt
there's nothing wrong with having a hive
mind that's based on conservative ideals
and Etc and they're trying to all put
together ideas of how to move forward
how to move the economy how to move
their own thesis of the world forward
but when it turns into a mob then it
becomes a real problem and it's too fast
for anybody to deal with it's not like
the police can just show up and say hey
guys can you go home this is dangerous
it happens as you said 42 billion
dollars can disappear overnight
and we don't know the outcomes of that
and if people realize they have this
power what is the backlash from the
state as well because it's good to have
this power but it's also
power is dangerous and then the state
are going to feel threatened and they're
going to try and get more power which is
one of the big battles we've all been
facing is stay overreach how does this
all play out I mean one of the ways it's
going to play out I think people are
dead right in the financial markets is
eventually we get rid of all of them the
smaller Banks we end up at bigger Banks
and eventually they become conduits for
the Federal Reserve via Central Bank
digital currencies the us is going to be
last in that equation the Europeans
they're going to be much sooner we're
already seeing it rolling out in many
many places and that is a way of kind of
this financial Weaponry between the
state and the people which is concerning
now there's upsides to Central Bank
digital currencies too I think they do a
great job in certain things and
terrifying in others and this battle
will mean that the the state takes more
power than it should do in a way to keep
itself relevant so is your base case
right now that uh these individual banks
in the private sector the smaller ones
fail get Consolidated kind of disappear
uh over time uh everyone gets
concentrated into the major Banks those
major Banks essentially get nationalized
and then are used as part of uh the
Central Bank digital currency and
Federal Reserve System or is it more of
hey there's only four or five of you
major Banks and if you want to kind of
play with us then you just are going to
execute on uh our plan or our technology
but the government doesn't actually have
to nationalize them in order to be able
to do it yeah I think it's the latter I
think the latter is
We're The Regulators you do what we say
you can get rich
um but we will we will um Make You Dance
and it's as simple as that and that's
the end of autonomy
um and we're seeing that blurring of
autonomy between the Federal Reserve and
the treasury as well that happened in
2020. so all of this is becoming a the
financial construct is becoming a
political construct as well
um
and again you know this is one of the
reasons and we'll get into crypto I'm
sure later why crypto is hugely powerful
in positions like this
it's a way out it's a life raft as I've
called it the last thing that I want to
talk about on the macro side is uh the
Federal Reserve at the end of 2021 kind
of the top of the market they said oh
you know this is hot uh from an
inflation standpoint we need to go ahead
and tighten Financial conditions and so
we're going to start to execute on that
I don't think a lot of people believe
them or was listening at first uh and so
it definitely caught you know many
people by surprise
um but if we now look maybe you know 15
to 18 months later the Federal Reserve
has taken interest rates from zero to
four point five percent or so and they
have dumped about a trillion dollars off
of the fed's balance sheet but they
never got the official CPI reading below
six percent
and if we do head back towards some sort
of quantitative easing loose monetary
policy regime is that a major problem
like they basically threw as much as
they could at this thing and they never
got it below six percent yet that seems
wildly concerning okay this is the
problem is there's too many non-macro
people talking about macro and just yeah
I've been in this business for 32 years
and
so many new people have come into the
market they check a chart of 1970 he
said that's going to repeat they then
make wild claims that monetary policies
inflationary and the cost of goods goes
up because of monetary policy that
doesn't seem to be the case it inflates
asset prices they then look immediately
at 2008 and say see this is what's going
to happen and they don't do the work on
all of this and the work on all of this
is firstly
there is a clear path that has been in
existence for the last
60 years of the lags and leads of
economic indicators
so for example the currently the China
credit impulse leads by I'm just looking
at my chart here about 17 months
and then looking forwards with stuff got
like
new orders less inventories that leads
by about three or four months
but when I go back and see what lags
well CPI lags by at least six months
wages by 13 months and Shelter by 16
months
if you look at the trueflation which is
this unchain inflation metric they're
showing inflation the US is currently
4.1 my forward-looking indicators based
on all of the work on the business cycle
and it's not really Voodoo it's pretty
straightforward that stuff is showing we
get to two percent or even below by the
summer
my work suggests we've got a decent
chance that inflation goes negative
what we've got is a bunch of people on
Twitter looking at inflation today and
saying oh my God it's six percent
but in fact actual real-time inflation
is 4.1 percent and forward-looking
inflation is probably below two percent
and this is what the FED gets wrong it
always tightens for the public narrative
and the public narrative is rates uh
inflation is too high
if you look at the commodity prices
almost every single one of them is now
down year on year they're deflating some
of them like Nat gas around 75 percent
contrary to the public Doom of which
they were saying well the Europeans are
going to be chipping their frozen bodies
off the streets in the winter because
there's no gas the opposite happened
so people just think that this inflation
that they see today is the future and
it's wrong it's wrong every time and
life's
studied every single inflation episode
the speed of which it comes down
it's based also on a hypothesis that
okay the world has changed and we're
deglobalizing and that's inflationary
okay well let's check that fact the fact
is that globalization percent uh global
trade has been trading sideways since
2008 so it hasn't contracted and it
hasn't grown
then there's a kind of nonsense argument
at the bis that oh an old population
they're suddenly inflationary because
they spend money
and that's utter garbage because anybody
who's had their parents retire realizes
you're faced with I've got a fixed pool
of assets and an unknown longevity of
life
if I run out of my money when I'm 85
years old that's the worst thing that
could possibly happen so all they do is
the collapse they're spending there is
no inflation spending boom to come out
of retired Baby Boomers they're
terrified of running out of money when
they're older so I don't see that
argument as well then there's the well
there's a structural Supply issue with
commodities and therefore Commodities
will go up now that's true
but commodity inflation is not inflation
shelter and wages are
um they're the more structural side of
inflation and commodity inflation is
cyclical so will we have inflation
Rising again in the next upside of the
business cycle maybe 20 25 2026 for sure
is it going to exceed what we've just
seen almost zero chance because we would
have to see a rate of change increase
higher than we just had with a Russian
invasion of Ukraine and the supply chain
shocks post-pandemic
so the probability is we will always see
inflation pick up in the cycle but it's
nowhere near what people think Trend
rate of GDP growth has been falling for
60 years now
if GDP is measured by productivity
growth population growth and debt growth
the debt growth of the equation has
basically stopped debt growth is just
there to issue
um debt growth is just there to pay off
existing interest payments
activity growth that's been declining
because of an aging population and will
continue to do so until technology kicks
in fully and population growth will that
stop too a because the world has now
stopped producing as many people and
most countries have closed their borders
somewhat
so we've got falling GDP growth we've
got a demographic that doesn't want to
spend money we have an overly indebted
system
and I think the probability of creating
inflation like we've just seen is a
false narrative
creating asset inflation from debasing
currency
yes that's likely to happen so I think
the Federal Reserve to call victories a
j-pal can put himself on the front cover
of a book and hero worship His God Paul
volcker is very simple he just wants to
see inflation fall below fed funds rate
now is he going to get that chance
before he has to cut I don't know but
current inflation is below fed funds
rate if you believe that true fellation
forecast which is like hundreds of
thousands of real-time prices on chain
and totally accessible and
understandable
so I think they got to that point of
super tight monetary policy and also
another thing people don't realize is
we've got two other big things happening
on the inflation front one is a banking
crisis is about the single biggest
deflationary event you could possibly
have because it stops Banks lending it
is also a a indicator of massive
deflationary pressure because you've got
a debt deflation so that is underway
would not be happening otherwise that's
why the Savings and Loan crisis happened
as well came out of the big inflation on
the other side as rates have gone up too
far and it broke the banking system
additionally you've got to throw in the
nuclear bomb that we just set off with
AI
gpt4 is
easily the most deflationary Global
event the world has ever seen in the
shortest period of time
and I just do not see how you can
generate inflation I don't think a lot
of these tech jobs
or knowledge economy jobs are ever
coming back it's kind of like car
workers from Pittsburgh I mean steel
workers from Pittsburgh car workers in
Detroit or steel workers in Sheffield or
coal miners in England their jobs never
came back and I just don't think that's
going to happen I think there's
hundreds of thousands of accountants
lawyers artists video editors producers
everything I mean sorry for anybody
watching this to realize is the world
has changed so fast that we can't even
get our heads around it
why does the Federal Reserve continue to
use the official CPI number versus more
of these real-time data points like a
trueflation uh even if they were
calculating let's say shelter rather
than kind of doing the Antiquated call
people up and ask them what they could
rent their home for uh they could just
maybe use one of the internet services
that has hundreds of millions of data
points in real time like why are they
still using the old data set if it is so
clear that the more accurate
um kind of more modern more real-time
data sets are telling them something
that may be uh different than the
official number
I kind of guess it's a political process
so you know one of the things the Biden
Administration wants is inflation to be
lower so they could say we beat
inflation for you don't we manage an
economy well you know all of this kind
of stuff
so and he'll say you know this came out
of a pandemic and they can blame it on
the Republicans whatever it is right so
I think it's actually a political
process
and we're seeing that political process
playing out with Liz Warren who's going
after as are others going after Jay pal
saying so what you want to do is get
inflation down we get it but you want to
get people out of jobs well
unfortunately that's how you slow down
an economy
and
that
whole process I think is a political
process as opposed to an economic
process I don't believe the thousand
phds of the FED are that stupid I mean
anybody with a you know Excel
spreadsheet can see the forward-looking
data
um and they know it's there so the FED
know it too
but I think that also they don't mind in
bringing interest rates lower than it
should do so they try and absolutely
kill inflation
to bring interest rates right down
because then they can service the debt
uh and that's a bigger issue is how to
service the debt the interest payments
on the debt both in the private sector
level and the public level
so right now the um the US economy if
you take the private sector debt and the
public debts are about 220 of GDP
GDP grows at about uh
one and three quarter percent a year
so if it interest rates let's assume
just for easy maths let's easy math say
the economy grows at two percent a year
if interest rates grow two percent
well the private sector alone is because
GDP is all the activity in the economy
that pays the interest so if GDP is at
two percent and interest rates are at
two percent then the private sector eats
a hundred percent of GDP growth
but the government also needs to fund
itself at two percent
and that would take away from GDP that's
what debt does so what it happens is and
I've worked this out mathematically is
that basically the FED monetizes
anything in excess of GDP growth okay
fine so as GDP has grown and debt has
grown that difference was about nine
trillion dollars which is lo and behold
roughly what the balance sheet was
but when you take out the pandemic
payments you can see that actually what
is happening is the Federal Reserve are
issuing new debt to pay the interest on
the old debt and then putting it on the
balance sheet and it happens three and a
half years later
and there's some beautiful charts I've
discovered I built myself with my
colleague Julian Bittle that show that
three and a half years later
the Federal Reserve monetized the
interest payments so why is that well
that's to do with the whole world
resetting rates at zero in 2009 so
everybody starts at zero everybody
refined then
and we've got most people have some
long-term debt and at least 60 of all
debt is in this two to five year sector
which is three and a half years
magically and that every three and a
half years is the peak of the business
cycle it's also the Bitcoin halving
cycle they're all correlated to the same
thing which is this debt cycle and so
when you get later when you need to stop
paying the interest the Federal Reserve
have to get interest rates down because
if not you can you keep compounding
negative GDP because the interest
payments if if the private sector is
paying four percent the state's paying
four percent well that's eight percent
of GDP and GDP is growing at two percent
well that's negative six percent of GDP
growth
and that just keeps compounding these
numbers don't change you cannot trade
change this trend rate of GDP growth
until you finally get a productivity
Miracle which I think is underway but
it's going to take another 10 years to
get there
so it's a really complicated process of
both politics debt management and then
kind of hiding it from everybody what
they're actually doing
one of the questions that I've gotten uh
probably the most over the last couple
of weeks is the Federal Reserve was
dropping one trillion dollars off their
balance sheet over the last 12 months
and then the week that Silicon Valley
Bank uh collapsed and kind of into the
next week the balance sheet increased by
300 billion dollars or so it was like
297 billion dollars is that quantitative
easing is that back to lose monetary
policy is there something else this [__]
makes me laugh every time there's always
somebody saying well actually it's not
quite quantitative easing or actually
quantitative easing doesn't quite make
it onto the into the markets and blah
blah blah blah blah blah
any increase in the central bank balance
sheet is debasement of the underlying
currency the S P 500 is 97 and a half
percent correlated to the FED balance
sheet actually even better the G4
Central the G5 central bank balance
sheets it's 97.5 correlated
if you divide it the s p by the FED
balance sheet there is zero growth in
the equity Market it looks just like the
European Equity Market
so all of this is is Optics but it's all
concept of easing is just forget the
term is are they printing money or not
and then there's a lot of well actually
people on Twitter so we're not printing
money because it doesn't do this doesn't
do that does it debase the currency has
it got an observable effect on asset
prices because when you debase a
currency
you debase the denominator the price of
assets optically Rises they don't
actually rise
it's because you've lowered that that is
measurable every time within ridiculous
statistical significance
but yet people are arguing over the
stupid terminology idea the FED balance
sheet went up therefore equities go up
when we see 300 billion in a week one of
the things that jumped to mind
immediately for me and I think was quite
shocking is it took us 12 months to get
a trillion dollars off the balance sheet
and we basically gave back a third of it
in a week
should we continue to expect the central
bank's balance sheet to expand and
eventually 10 trillion 15 20 trillion
and just kind of continue going up over
the coming years
yes because they have to pay the
interest on the debt
so you pay the interest on the debt that
keeps increasing the balance sheet so
it'll go up another couple of trillion
over the next you know
18 months or so but if you get any shock
in the middle it actually boosts it more
because they need to do extra which is
why the pandemic tacked on another two
and a half three trillion on the balance
sheet so maybe this will tack on another
trillion on the balance sheet 2 trillion
we don't know we don't know yet we need
to see
but you know the commercial real estate
market on the on these um smaller Banks
is about two trillion dollars
um now obviously not the whole lot's
insolvent blah blah blah but easy to
assume there's another trillion dollars
taxed on here plus the payment of the
interest payments so it wouldn't
surprise me if we don't see the balance
sheet at
12 trillion dollars in two years time so
it just keeps going there's there's no
way to stop it you can't reduce the
balance sheet which is increasing the
value of the denominator without asset
prices optically going down
people say oh the Federal Reserve they
want to kill this asset price inflation
there is no asset price inflation it's
the denominator going up and down so and
even PES are a function of this and I
can come on to that later
so if they lower the value of the assets
[__] blows up
duh it's collateral
right in a debt system you have interest
payments and you have the collateral
if you lower the value of the collateral
guess what this part blows up
and so they can't do it because the US
is 220 GDP in debt at that level then
add financial debt and it's over 350 of
GDP so you cannot allow for the
collateral
to go under it can't fall too much you
know if the collateral fell 50 this time
around the meaningful collateral of the
system stuff like
um
the S P 500 yeah Equity stuff or real
estate or stuff like that they can't
allow it because the whole system breaks
so what they need to do is they can
bring it down somewhat to slow down the
economy it tightens credit standards but
then they immediately have to reverse
and go the other way and they have to go
further than they've been and it's just
an endless stair step of them doing this
and there's no way around it
you mentioned earlier that inflation is
you know four percent or so with
trueflation you see Ford looking is
below two percent potentially even
negative I think somebody like Barry
stern look he thinks that it'll be
negative over the summer Kathy Wood uh
very worried about deflation
um in light of what is going on with the
banking crisis what does the Federal
Reserve do here if they step in and they
Shore up these Banks they continue to do
what it appears that they're doing does
that create the inflationary pressures
and would you expect us to go kind of
back up uh or do you think asset prices
respond by going back up but the actual
uh kind of consumer inflation uh would
likely just go sideways or potentially
even continue in the trend that it is
and continue dropping yeah I think
my view is the Federal Reserve
probably do 25 basis points this time
around because they want to show this
relationship of hey we got fed funds
above inflation so you can forget about
inflation expectations and the next move
from the Federal Reserve will be 100
basis points emergency cut and it might
even happen as soon as June just depends
what happens to the banks over the next
few weeks
um and then they just keep cutting and
QE comes back
so that is why the equity Market has not
been falling as something I've been
talking about for a while is
Equity Market is forward-looking the
nasdaq's more forward-looking the s p uh
the NASDAQ already priced in a recession
and it priced it in by October of last
year and it's forward-looking so it's
starting to say well liquidity is coming
back into the system crypto is even more
forward-looking and that's why you know
a lot of crypto bottomed in June the
respondent in October
um so that's forward-looking
so asset prices will go up because
you're lowering the value of the
denominator so Optical it goes up the
only two that actually outperform the
FED balance sheet is crypto and Tech
because they've got secular
Trends behind them
does it bring inflation okay so let's
say the Federal Reserve cut through
under basis points
do quantitative easing
to take some of the [__] off the balance
sheets of these smaller Banks and help
the larger Banks
well are they going to increase the
lending or not
there's almost zero chance we've seen
this exact playbook in Europe it's the
same thing so Europe 2012 is exactly the
US in 2023 and what happens is they stop
Lending and they'll never lend again
and so that's the end of that story and
so if there's less lending available
then inflation is not available you've
also got as I said the massive we've got
unemployment to come
rents to come down wages to come down
it's all part of the that flow of Time
how this happens so the probability is
look if they do all of this stuff in 18
months time we're dealing in the
inflation numbers because of this lag
with rents coming down
and they're going to come down a lot
because we've seen it from the Zillow
star wages also so in 18 months time
we're still going to see massive
disinflationary pressures even though
commodity prices might have bottomed and
started rising and that tends to be why
the Federal Reserve and the central
banks end up doing loose monetary policy
for at least two years after the bottom
of the business cycle because you get
these lagging effects of unemployment
and rents and unemployment is so
political that they have to show that
they're doing something because you know
in the middle of this is every two years
in the US is this political cycle as
well so it's a complicated mess I don't
think it's inflationary but I do think
asset prices uh rise significantly
how fast I think is the next big
question that people will have when it
comes to asset prices obviously Bellagio
srinivasan uh very publicly coming out
and saying he believes that Bitcoin will
hit one million dollars in the next 90
days not just saying it though also I
think he's up to two million dollars
that he's bet in this public manner uh
that it's going to happen I think there
may be some confusion or debate in terms
of whether he is claiming that there is
going to be hyperinflation or there is
simply going to be kind of an Awakening
globally of bitcoin's value proposition
which would then drive the price higher
how do you look at how quickly asset
prices uh could rally on something like
this and then what is your current view
of Bitcoin itself
so
so generally speaking over time the
observable
relationship because it's a 97.5
correlation between the G5 central bank
balance sheets and the S P 500 is every
time it grows by one percent or shrinks
by one percent the equity Market moves
by two percent
so we've got a clear relationship and so
I don't know we just increased the
balance sheet by whatever it was five
percent let's say so therefore Equity
markets go up 10 that that's that's
roughly how it works
however
NASDAQ goes up at a multiplier about 1.4
times the s p because it's got a
technological uptrend and it's probably
accelerating as AI Robotics and all of
these things come in and crypto's got a
multi a much bigger multiplier
so let's go back to the last time we saw
this which was
December 21st 2018 the FED just stopped
and said right we're not going to
increase the balance sheet we're not
going to raise rates any further not
going to decrease the balance sheet not
going to raise rates any further over
the next six months crypto is up 300 so
Bitcoin did 300 and something percent
um the exponential age stocks which are
the really kind of growthy Arc style
stocks they were up about
no sorry 30 the NASDAQ was about 22
something of that magnitude the s p was
about 15 percent
um and so we can see that relationship
happens
so
my view here is
I got into Bitcoin
so assets will go up according to the
balance sheet I think the balance sheet
goes up significantly 30 plus overtime
therefore the equity Market can go up
60 percent in the s p maybe more so new
all-time highs in the next 12 months or
so maybe a bit longer
um NASDAQ gets there sooner because of
its relationship
um crypto moves very fast
I got into Bitcoin in 2013 because I
lived the European banking crisis and
obviously the financial crisis but the
European banking crisis was very similar
to what's happening now the local Bank
in the village that I went in went under
and took everybody's deposits they
bailed them in
um we had a run on deposits liquidity
issues they were invested in things that
were illiquid which was real estate real
estate market had come under pressure
very very similar too many small banks
in Europe
um and so draggy backed up the whole lot
that whole situation
um I forgotten where I was going with
this now
the banks are uh why you got into
Bitcoin yeah so I saw this
and I realized that there was no trust
in the financial system I nobody knew
who owned what when Lehman went under
and they were terrified of others going
under because of the same issue because
the daisy chains are collateral
everywhere in this market
and then when you realize in a bank
you don't actually own your money
and people are now realizing that
and the treasure in the FED are like
well well we'll just pretend that's okay
that drives people into this parallel
Financial system I got into Bitcoin in
2013 for exactly this reason
and have been an active participant of
the market ever since and so I think
what Balaji is saying is listen guys
here's the life raft you can take it
now bitcoin's relationship with the FED
balance sheet is really interesting
because
it goes up exponentially so if I look at
it versus M2 year on year or the FED
balance sheet year on year it massively
outperforms in the bull market and then
pulls back when the liquidity comes out
of the system again but it keeps going
up
so yes I think there is a
potential setup here for Bitcoin and the
whole crypto Market actually to
be shockingly strong more like 2013 than
2019 2019 we had that big correction and
that was partly due to this GeForce G5
central bank balance sheets some of them
were Contracting over that period of
time and it pulled back the crypto
Market this time around I don't think
we're going to see that I think we're
going to see all of the central banks
falling into place because there's
banking issues both in Europe and the US
and China has its own issues so that
they've all got the same issue which is
debt they're all going to have to
stimulate so I think it's more likely to
play out like 2013 which is very squeezy
then sideways consolidation then very
squeezy
um because you know every time we go
through these Cycles
more and more people understand what the
benefit is of Bitcoin
and now we've got 300 million people
that have used Bitcoin and other crypto
the next time around it'll be
a billion people
or 600 million people hey whatever the
number is
and those people will have been awoken
to the fact that there is another way
out of this
now the issue is as we all know is
Bitcoin is extremely volatile
so it's very hard to think of it in
terms of
well it's a wealth preservation asset
because people's mind time Horizon is
too short but if you hold it long enough
it does extremely well it does better
than the FED balance sheet better than
any other asset in existence but people
get freaked out by the up and down move
but if they just zoomed out they say it
does a phenomenal job at opting out the
financial system over time
but you know maybe you need to keep
liquidity and other stuff
for when you need it as opposed to the
crypto cycle which can be quite vicious
when people hear that Bitcoin could go
up uh aggressively in price uh there's a
cohort of those individuals who then
jump and say well the government may not
want that or the government may try to
stop that from happening
um people will point to uh politics some
people will point though to Capital
controls that usually happen when there
is some sort of high inflation or
hyperinflationary event and everyone is
trying to get out of a currency those
Capital control controls get put in
place and basically try to lock in the
citizens we've seen that literally
happen the last two or three years in
various countries around the world is
that what your expectation would be as
well is that there would be some sort of
you know Capital control whether
directly or indirectly uh that people
wouldn't be able to get out into crypto
or do you think that that is more so
just Twitter fodder and not necessarily
a concern
so if we go back to our conversation
earlier about Bank runs and we said
you know
you either kind of guarantee the system
or you try and throttle it
my view is the US understands crypto
understands that it is the answer to the
Future
but they need to throttle it because if
you create the bank run on the entire
system
then the unintended consequences are
simply gigantic but it's kind of
everybody losing their jobs the entire
system breaking apart the entire system
of the United States has been the world
leader or Europe and all this falls
apart
they don't want that but I think they
understand that there is a future here
but there's a battle to get people
across because some people can't stand
it they don't like the idea of it other
people understand it but don't want it
to happen too fast and I get that
so I think that there will be an ongoing
War
and if Balaji gets across what he wants
to do which is
more get more people to move out of the
system into the Bitcoin Market we'll see
the pushback coming but it happens very
quickly because the mob is pretty fast
as we know and the marble the hive mind
who's deciding let's go to the parallel
Financial system they can move really
fast
so the government's going to try and
stop it but you know they do have you
know as Punk 6529 talks about there is a
freedom to transact here you need the
ability to do that and if they go
against that then they're really trying
to change the political
Spectrum entirely and I think that the
pushback would be so gigantic but it is
going to be a fight
but within this fight is a bigger world
the US has been down this route before
it tends to get
self-protecturally at various points
so after the the
after Nixon left the gold standard the
U.S essentially had capsule controls
and foreigners wanted dollars and they
couldn't get them
and the flow of dollars in foreign
exchange was restricted by the us
because they were protective
so what happened was England came up and
went well we're going to have the FX
Market here because we don't have the
same regulatory issues we will create
regulation to allow it to come and it
became the biggest Market on Earth
they then innovated again and then
basically invented the euro dollar
market and London was the center of the
euro dollar market the Euro dollars are
all dollars that are traded that are
outside the U.S system and it's gigantic
it's much bigger than the US system
itself and that came out of London and
then it spread to Global centers but
London was always the epicenter
then after that came the derivative
Market the U.S had its listed
derivatives and it didn't want the banks
to get involved with Structured Products
and OTC derivatives and all of this
stuff
the swaps Market the whole lot all went
to London because London said we'll
change the regulation to get this so
London was the largest financial center
in the world by a big margin for a long
time
then comes brexit and then comes Basel
three the US cheats on Basel three and
says we're only going to let the big
banks have to be
um have to be regulated in this way so
they can't fail but the small Banks they
can do what they want guess what
suddenly it blows up Europeans forced
Basel three on everybody as in the UK so
they don't have some of the same issues
they've got different issues obviously
so
that whole mechanism
plus brexit meant that the capital the
world's Capital markets went back to New
York
and they were and they they've been in
New York for the last 10 years or so
but the UK is looking like it wants to
regulate crypto in a very sensible way
they understand regulatory Arbitrage
better than any country on Earth you see
once the US screws up and misses an
opportunity the UK has the rule of law
the language the ability for Americans
to go and live and work there it's a
global Capital center it's connected
with Singapore the Cayman Islands Hong
Kong the UAE all of the places that
matter has a broader relationship on a
on a less aggressive
um policy
so my guess is we don't know whether
this government will last in the UK or
not but if it does the UK will probably
eat the US's lunch and we'll see
coinbase we'll see Kraken we'll see
Circle we'll see everybody relocations
to the UK because it's an easy easy
change to have and don't forget this is
a trillion dollar industry it's three
trillion dollars a peak what's it going
to be at next Peak by 10 trillion
probably
so of course the UK wants it because
it's lost relevancy so the US has to be
very careful what it does here I don't
think it stops the people per se
getting involved I think it tries to
regulate that that's all well and good I
think it's trying to stop the
infrastructure layer being built and
becoming too powerful too decentralized
so they can regulate coinbase and maybe
they can regulate Circle but they don't
want too many moving Parts in all of
this but if that's the case if they're
too heavy-handed in a global world that
capsule is going to flow elsewhere and
then every pension fund Sovereign wealth
fund hedge fund anybody else wanting to
do business in cryptocurrencies will go
to London and we'll go to Singapore
they'll go to the UAE they'll go to Hong
Kong and that's the way the world works
should the United States Federal Reserve
buy Bitcoin today and put it into those
reserves as a hedge against all of the
chaos all of the uncertainty all of the
problems that we talked about or do you
think it is either too early or not
prudent for them to do that right now
they don't need to hold Reserve so the
world's Reserve currency they just print
dollars
and build gunships and space Rockets so
no they don't need this
do other countries do this for sure you
know we've seen it we've seen it and we
know the Middle East and others have
woken up to this because of what
happened to their the Russian dollar
Reserves
so other countries may be incentivized
to do it but it's a very volatile asset
so really and I've talked about this in
the past Sovereign wealth funds if it's
better in than it fits in bank
treasuries because it's it's just in in
central bank treasuries because it's so
volatile so I don't think the US does it
more contentious question is
who owns all of that um Satoshi Nakamoto
stuff my theory has been from day one
that this was a combination of the gchq
in the UK and the NSA and the US that
built this no
I suppose the Department of Defense
several times over the years and they
don't know where Bitcoin came from
but they kind of are open to the idea
that it came as a parallel system that
was built as a just in case by
State actors themselves
knowing that it's decentralized but it
but if they can play a central role in
it it's okay so I don't know maybe
that's the state that they already own
who knows
it is um it's very interesting to think
about what people uh perceive to happen
here in the future uh especially in the
coming year or so what are you doing
differently in your portfolio are you
selling certain types of assets are you
buying certain types of assets are you
trying to hold certain things based on
your world view uh kind of coming into
more of this crisis
so at a top level macro position
I haven't cashed out of a single penny
of crypto and all I've done is use the
cycle when the liquidity cycle hits the
long-term uptrend that started happening
in June uh of last year to just add to
my positions uh that's all I've done now
there are some trading opportunities
around like bonds because I think bond
yields go from four percent to one and a
half percent so can you make money will
you make more money in crypto for sure
but
people don't want the risk and people
are such Dex online about the kind of
risks you have to run to do it but yes
there's traditional answers you could
buy gold you can buy
um bonds you can probably buy technology
stocks or you can buy crypto and you
skin the cat anywhere you want it in
terms of what risk profile and I've
talked about my risk profile is you know
I have income
I have assets that are paid for
so I can take more risk with the um
liquidity that I have you know I don't
do VC because I don't like a 13-year
payout I like to be in control I'm a
hedge fun guy at heart so I like to be
in control of my liquidity and so I
haven't changed anything at all in terms
of my asset allocation apart from
increasing it and using the leverage so
why am I doing this and this is a really
important for people to understand so I
first bought Bitcoin in at 200 in 2013.
it went straight up to
a thousand dollars
and I'm like I'm clearly George Soros
I'm the best investor the world's ever
seen 500 in three months I'm a genius it
then Falls
87 percent
and my time Horizon was like five years
plus so I'm like well maybe probably 10
years because I wrote that first ever
macroeconomic strategy paper about
Bitcoin 2013. so I said okay fine so
it's a call option I'll let it go up and
down trip fell didn't do anything
watched it it Rose 2017
I got confused over the staking Wars uh
the forking Wars and I'm like I don't
know what's going on here I'm gonna take
my money out and I sold out at something
like two thousand dollars so I've made
10 times my money
one of the Best Bets I've ever made and
watched it now still interested in
crypto but I just I thought it was it
was in a bubble and it was it shot up 10
x more to 20 000 then collapsed 85 or 82
whatever it did that time around and
then I bought it again
really well in kind of April 2020 when
it fell into the middle of the wedge
pattern I bought it right the right
level you know I didn't get the absolute
low but let's say I got in about six
nine thousand and then I put in a much
bigger bet than I did first time around
and great
so I went back recently and looked at it
and thought well somebody just kept my
original 200 in its original size
because it looked like I traded it
really well I bought it here I sold it
here and then bought it there problem is
is the here's and theirs were all higher
because I sold at 2 000 and bought back
in at six and a half
I [__] the whole thing up really if I
just held it I'd have made five times as
much money
and then the real magic unfolded is if I
use the liquidity Cycles
and bought them every time we've had
that kind of M2 fall down M2 growth fall
down Global M2 growth bringing it back
to the long term uptrend and just by
bought then I the crypto Winters
even if you just missed the Low by 30
maybe more I still would have done over
20 times better
even accounting for the fact I put a lot
more in in
um April 2020. so
I've learned many of us are having to
learn how to trade a exponential asset
that's in a logarithmic uptrend that is
cyclical
um but that's how I just deal with it
now I just use that simple framework is
the adoption going on and where are we
in the liquidity cycle and just use that
what is your best argument for why the
United States dollar will end up
continuing to be the global Reserve
currency and then what would be your
best argument as to why you think it
will not in our lifetime be the global
Reserve currency
87 of all World traders in US dollars
and a vast majority of global debt is in
US dollars
the U.S economy itself is the largest
invested economy as a percentage of
global GDP in world history but then
everybody else has dollar debt so the
world is something like 400 of GDP in
debt
of which at least 50 percent of it may
be more maybe 70 percent of it is US
dollar debt so you need dollars or
everybody goes bust
that's why the dollar keeps going up
people just don't understand
is that everybody has dollar debts
and all traders in dollars so you need
dollars
and the less money there is in the
system
the more desperate you are in that game
of musical chairs to get those bloody
dollars to pay your debt or you go bust
that mechanism is not going to change in
fact it may get much worse
over time we're seeing the Chinese the
Russians others trying to move away from
this but it's really hard because if
your debts are in dollars if you're
South Korea you don't want bloody yawn
you want dollars you need dollars for
your entire banking system
so I don't see
a route by which that changes and the US
is also a geopolitical force the largest
geopolitical force and they will force
people to use dollars by coercion
so can that fall apart
it can if you debase your currency
enough which is kind of it's not
hyperinflation it's a different route to
it and it will it can lead to the same
thing
bloody difficult to do with this much
debt around
unless they suddenly printed 50 trillion
dollars
um
so
I think it happens over time
and it happens because the dollar is too
strong not because it's too weak
and the stronger the dollar gets the
more it chokes and forces people to find
Alternatives whether that's
cryptocurrency for a lot of people I
think Bitcoin will work for a lot of
people over time once the volatility of
it comes down as the adoption keeps
Rising
um and others will form regional trade
groups and we'll have maybe Global
currencies there's no reason we can't
start creating Global Currency baskets
um as on on chain as a stable coin it
doesn't have to be a US dollar stable
coin
and you know if we think about the euro
dollar market the stable coin Market is
basically the euro dollar market except
it's democratized so everybody can get
hold of the dollar if you're in the
Philippines or in Nigeria you can get
your two dollars and send it to your
aunt instantaneously
um the euro dollar market doesn't allow
that you have to go through the bank and
say please sir and they said no you're
not big enough you don't deserve the
dollars this is the politics but this
democratizes access to dollars
no real reason that the UK let's say
let's say the UK actually goes ahead
doing this doesn't create the
the euro dollar market on chain the Euro
stablecoin Market
um and we could have baskets of
currencies which we've not really done
before so therefore you could trade a
commodity basket currency or a
technology basket currency so it matches
your
customers with your needs because like
let's say South Africa their currency
goes up and down because it's a poorly
managed economy but they're also
beholden to the uh commodity cycle
and that's driven by the dollar
but if they dealt directly with China
and the EU maybe they don't need to have
the dollar in the middle of it so I
think it happens over time and it
happens because the Dollar's too strong
and it forces people to do it it doesn't
happen I don't think in a collapse of
the dollar I think it's the opposite
which is this dollar milkshake theory
that Brent Johnson calls talks about
my last question for you is uh balaji's
one million uh dollar Bitcoin in 90 days
uh begs the question what do you think
happens to Bitcoin in the next 90 days
maybe 12 months and then maybe five
years or their price points that you
look at you and I know to give price
projections online right now is the way
that the the hive mind turns into a mob
and tries to Lynch you assuming that
like what we speak is the truth and we
know exactly where it's going to go so
my answer is
he's got 0.0 chance of being right but
what he is doing is spending a million
bucks on two million bucks on marketing
what is an important concept and I think
that is that is fine I get it
um
my my general thesis is the Market's
going to be squeezier Than People expect
so I think we'd probably get to 50 000
faster than most people expect
when that is is it this year is it is it
within 12 months
probably
don't know and over time we just keep
the adoption curve and it keeps going so
you know where does it go at the peak of
this cycle I don't know again I don't
want to be hung by dicks online for all
of this but you know over time does it
take out a hundred thousand does it take
it 250 000 of course it does it's just a
matter of when and the timing part is
the red herring you know if you've got a
long enough time Horizon and the trend
rate of adoption and the rise in the
price of the asset over time beats all
other assets you're under no motivation
to do anything else but hold
I think that is a great place to end
well thank you so much for doing this uh
every time I talk to you especially in
moments of Crisis I always learn
something and find the uh the
conversations both entertaining uh and
informative so we will definitely do it
again in the future hopefully next time
uh in a raging bull market and not
during a moment of crisis
my takeaway for people here
is this is not 2008 all over again
it is a messy ugly credit crisis
but we have a Magic Bullet which is
quantitative easing quantitative easing
plus rate Cuts will stop the financial
crisis exactly as draghi stopped it in
2012.
however
they'll debase your currency by doing it
and we know the answer and the outcome
and that is what Bitcoin is there for
and if you don't like Bitcoin
then there are other assets to own such
as technology stocks or even gold that
will do okay they will rise to offset
that debasement of currency so that's
what's coming
either way you lose your money in the
bank
or they devalue your money via value
devaluing the denominator so just be
prepared for that and then you can just
chill through this whole mess
I appreciate it very much we'll
definitely do it again in the future
all right my friends good to see you